dawn has risen over a wednesday in
southern nevada beautiful view from our
camera on top of the bank of america
rainbow in the 95.
this the these are the gas stations
where we normally look to see how fast
the flags are moving around in whipping
wind but we don't have any wind in fact
if anything we might have a little bit
of haze as we're looking across the
valley sun came up at 5 23 the official
temperature for las vegas at reading
international is 83 but we do have some
readings in the mid 70s before things
start to turn around now that the sun's
up but enjoy your 75 up there in aliante
same thing goes for centennial hills and
for sky canyon boy walking the dog going
out for jog now is the best time to do
it before things really crank up 79
hanging on to the 70s and mountains
engine roads ranch that's going to turn
around quickly warm spots going to be
some 83's downtown sunrise mountain
green valley henderson and again we are
looking for temperatures to be a couple
degrees warmer than they were yesterday
i got up to 113 out of death valley
yesterday close to triple digits still
at five o'clock in the morning 86 in
laughlin 81 for searchlight good morning
boulder city you're at 82 always a
little bit cooler up in lincoln county
and in white pine county for ely so we
only made it to 101 yesterday we we're
going for 103 but we're still sticking
with 106 for the high today current
temperature the low so far this morning
so both of these numbers about 10
degrees above normal record high for
today that's not going anywhere but in
the eight day forecast in just a second
we're going to reinforce the record and
record high temperatures so excessive
heat warnings running through saturday
night for northwestern arizona through
sunday night for us here in clark county
and in southern california bottom line
just trying to raise awareness and make
sure we're staying careful out there
this high pressure and the jet stream
are sending storminess around us these
are some severe thunderstorms for parts
of oklahoma and texas other severe
storms in wisconsin illinois and alabama
stretching into georgia
we're going to go to 107 tomorrow 109
for friday and saturday looks like it
will be a record for friday tying the
record for saturday these are the record
high temperatures in red here for the
next several days